(box clattering)
- [Narrator] Your last pizza probably came
in a box like this.
It's cardboard, sturdy
and most importantly,
keeps your cheese from
getting stuck to the lid.
And that's thanks to Domino's.
This founder is widely credited
with creating the corrugated pizza box.
It's just one of the
company's innovations,
not in pizza, but in delivery.
(doorbell ringing)
In 2022, more than 40%
of online delivery orders
for major pizza chains were from Domino's.
Here's how the company made its name
in the pizza delivery market
and why this foundational piece
of its business is facing new challenges.
This is the economics of Domino's.
♪ Domino's Pizza delivers ♪
- [Narrator] Domino's,
originally called DomiNick's,
acquired its first restaurant
in 1960 in Ypsilanti, Michigan,
and jumped into the delivery
business the same year.
Something very few restaurants
were doing at the time.
- Now we think of delivery
as being so ubiquitous.
I mean, so many types of
restaurants have delivery
but Domino's was there
very early at scale.
- [Narrator] One reason
it's become so well known
for its delivery is a
campaign the company started
in the '80s promising delivery in.
- [Announcer 1] Less than 30 minutes.
- [Announcer 2] Within 30 minutes.
- [Announcer 3] Only
Domino's Pizza delivers
in 30 minutes or less.
- People really did have the sense
that once they ordered that pizza,
they were gonna get it
to their homes quickly
and I think that really
helped for marketing.
- [Narrator] Domino's ended
that guarantee in 1993
after a delivery driver struck
another vehicle resulting
in a lawsuit.
But by then, the company had
cemented its place in delivery
and in the half century
since Domino's was founded, it's paid off.
It took the biggest slice of
pizza chain sales in 2022.
Domino's success is due in part
to creativity in every step
of its delivery process,
starting with stores.
Many are small and often with
little or no dining space,
a model the company has said allowed
for lower rents and
reduced store expenses.
Over the years.,
Domino's has also focused
on establishing more
than 6,500 locations in the US
and has worked with franchisees
to extend their reach.
- So one part of Domino's strategy
is what's called fortressing,
which is making sure
there's enough pizza shops
in a certain mile radius,
that wherever your order goes,
one of those pizza shops can handle it
and it can help get it
to your house quickly.
- [Narrator] The company
supply line is also structured
to make the pizza creation process
as quick and uniform as possible.
Domino's has 25 supply chain centers
in the US where dough is mixed
and toppings are prepared
before being sold
to franchise stores where
pizzas are assembled and baked.
The more pizzas that are sold,
the more money Domino's
makes from its supply chain.
It made up 59% of
Domino's revenue in 2021.
The next part of the process is ordering.
In 2008, the company rolled out
its advanced online ordering system,
which included a customized pizza builder
and the Pizza Tracker.
- So the Pizza Tracker is
something that Domino's invented.
They will let you know
where it is in the process.
It's whether it's being cooked,
whether it's out for delivery,
where they're approaching.
- [Narrator] Domino's has continued
to introduce new ordering options.
- Pizza emoji scent, Domino's
ordered, smiley face.
- [Narrator] Then there's
the last step of the process,
getting the pizza from
the kitchen to your home.
From working with special kinds
of insulated bags to
creating 3D car top signs,
Domino's has been a big
innovator in this step.
The company has experimented
with several methods
of delivery vehicles,
(helicopter whirring)
helicopters, electric bikes,
self-driving cars, even cars
with a heated pizza oven.
- It's really putting the whole brand
behind delivery in a lot of ways.
- [Narrator] But after years
at the top of delivery,
Domino's is facing new challenges.
Companies like Uber Eats, GrubHub
and DoorDash are eating at
Domino's business in the US
as drivers leave pizza for
apps with more flexible hours.
It's contributed
to an industry-wide
delivery driver shortage.
Other chains like Papa John's
and Pizza Hut have both started working
with some of these apps,
but Domino's has resisted.
- They argue that that
makes it more profitable
because you're not having
to pay an outside service
to deliver that pizza and to
market that pizza on their app
and it keeps 'em closer
to their customers.
- [Narrator] As the company
has faced these issues,
its shares have slumped from
a high at the end of 2021.
Now Domino's is exploring new options.
The company is building out a fleet
of electric delivery vehicles
to recruit new drivers
and it's now offering customers
what it calls a $3 tip
to pick up their own pie.
- [Announcer 4] We see
you, carry out heroes.
- You know, it's much cheaper for them
if their customers pick up their own pizza
and so they are getting in
the pickup game in a big way.
- [Narrator] As Domino's
continues to grapple
with these issues, investors
and customers will be watching
for future innovations.
(lively music)